hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the sleaze
meister trap which derives from the
alakan defense which is pawn to e4
knight to f6 so if you play this as
black you definitely may have some
opportunities to
deploy this trap now white's most common
move is just to push forward here with
e5
second most common move which is what
this variation is based on is
knight to c3 now black can play
the the more common e5 which getting
into the vienna game which
could definitely get into the four
nights game very very easily
but in this variation we're actually
going to be playing the move pawn
to d5 now from here
they push forward with e5 kind of
delaying that one move
uh and now getting into the main line
here and then black's gonna play
knight two e4 now they could always take
here and then we recapture
uh he puts him in a pretty tough spot as
far as they want to develop their knight
here to f3
they can't really do that so most
players are not going to capture right
here
if you run this through a computer
engine actually recommends the move
knight to e2 which is where
we're going to be focused here and
black's going to push forward with
d4 and this is where the trap is going
to come into play and it really starts
with white thinking that they have
something that they don't actually have
they're trying to lay their own trap
into let this be a lesson
as you look at this to make sure that
you're always looking at what your
opponent can do
so you don't fall into a trap that maybe
they're putting you into
and the trap for white would be if they
play pawn to c3 which seems logical
one it attacks this pawn here on d4
and it also opens up for the queen to
get involved into the game
and not only that but it allows them to
get into into the game
with check so after the move pawn to c3
they're almost hoping that you take here
on c3
and then they can play queen to a4 check
and then they are forking your knight
here on e4
looking to get an easy piece
now unfortunately for white this is not
going to work out as they had
hoped and really i think they're
expecting black to play maybe knight to
c6
and then queen captures here on e4 no
real good options for black to continue
or
same thing with bishop to d7 both of
those are going to end with
queen takes here on e4 the main thing
that white has to be careful of is the
move
knight to d7 it looks somewhat odd
because
all this does is it blocks the attack on
the king
but it also blocks the queen here on d8
and also blocks
the bishop here on c8 but this is the
trap
because after the queen takes here on e4
then the move knight to c5
is deadly because this knight is now
attacking the queen here on e4
and it's also attacking this square here
on d3 anytime your opponent plays their
knight here to e2 it's smothering their
own
king and so you can start to look for
opportunities to get your knight
involved into the game and
really attack these squares if they're
not protected by a pawn so the move you
can see here knight 2 d3
is very very powerful the square is
defended by the queen now here on
d8 so how does white continue well kind
of two moves here
we'll look at both e3 and d4 here the
first one is
e3 you can still see exactly what we
were talking about here and that's
the knight coming here to d3 check
king comes to d1 now the pawn
takes on b2 uh they have two options
one that they can go ahead and take with
their bishop they could move their rook
over here to a b1
if they re move their rook then pawn
takes here on c1
capturing that bishop promoting to a
queen the knight takes because
no reason to give up your rook here on
c1 so we take with our knight right here
and then after they take you can see
we're now up in
material uh as far as the pawn advantage
we also have
the bishop pair so this is going to be
good for black and also
their king is just in a really tough
spot can't castle um
it's out in the center of the board so
black definitely should have a good game
here if they capture with
their bishop that's fine as well we can
now take with our
knight check and after king 2e1 we can
just
even come back here to a d3
check maybe king d1 and then bishop to
g4 getting more material involved into
the game so let's come back maybe they
don't play queen to e3
what if they play instead queen to
d4 okay well here we can just play
knight 2 d3 as we talked about before
they go ahead and take here that they
can't just take our knight because then
we're just gonna take their queen that's
definitely not a good exchange for
for white so they play king 2 d1 now we
can go ahead and take their queen they
take
our queen but then we have the move
knight to f2
check we're now forking this rook here
on h1 so after they move the king
we played knight takes on h1 and you can
now see
we are up in material uh not only up in
pawns but also up in the fact that we
traded off
uh a knight for a rook so
uh definitely going to be a good
position from black standpoint so
instead of taking
early on you know we said that the queen
taking here on e4
is a mistake really what white should be
doing in this spot
is the move knight takes here on c3
if they do play knight takes here on c3
we're going to take our
knight here from e4 and we're going to
move it to
c5 this attacks the queen here on
a4 and after the queen moves back you
know it really could move back
anywhere then we're going to play the
move pawn to
c6 and this really stops a lot of the
threats that white has of bringing the
knight down here to
d5 or b5 it also opens up for the queen
to get involved
into the game you definitely don't want
to make a mistake and play you know
let's
you know knight takes here on e5 opens
up for the queen to get involved into
the game because then they could just
play
pawn to d4 and now they're forking both
of our knights so uh early on
if we look at this you know white really
had what almost seem like a trap of yeah
go ahead and take this pawn here because
then i can get the queen involved into
the game
but after we play the move knight to d7
which looks like it blocks off things
for black
uh this is actually the trap hoping that
they take
the knight here on e4 and then we just
play the move knight to
c5 but remember even if they don't if
they take here on
c3 we're still in a good spot we played
knight to c5
forcing the queen back and then we can
just continue with our game plan
pawn to c6 then we can play pawn to e6
at some point get our dark square
mission bomb to the game castle on
the king side is really the way that
we're going to continue so that is the
sleaze meister trap
always be wary of what your opponent's
going to do maybe sometimes you think
you're laying a trap but actually
they are hoping that you take specific
material just see all the threats they
have on board
especially if they have uh ways that
they can
get their queen involved into the game
and also if your king
looks like it is trapped in any capacity
that's definitely a red flag that you
have to pay attention to so hopefully
you guys enjoyed
this trap if you have other videos you
want me to make please let me know but
thank you guys so much for watching i'll
see you in the next video